in the category of animated short film
the nominees are
fifty percent gray we re Robinson and
Seamus burn for the birds Ralph
Eggleston give up your old sins
que Haga fini and Dara O'Connell strange
invaders Cordell Baca stubble trouble
Joseph E Meredith and the Oscar goes to
for the birds
Ralph a Gaston this is the first Academy
Award for Ralph pickle spoon for the
birds is his directorial debut and
animation the comedy short is about a
flock of birds perched on a wire
gosh a billion people this is great
I'd like to thank all of my friends and
family especially my mom and dad at
wooden little Elizabeth everyone at
Pixar in our friends at the Walt Disney
Company
Skywalker Sound Jory prohm and the
writers in the sky for their wonderful
sound work gosh Karen do fellow eye
producer James Ward Murphy and Bill wise
partners I would like to thank Steve
Jobs and Sarah MacArthur for their
encouraging the short films at Pixar and
most of all I'd like to thank Ed Catmull
and John Lasseter my friend and mentors
I hope each and every one of you get to
work with them as closely as I have
thank you very much